so you want to know my secret I am an
epic gamer that's right hate it or like
it I don't care Mike 80s is at least one
I play all the coolest gigs none of that
candy crush stuff like for tonight every
gamer we gamers will write because we
are the most oppressed group on the
Internet no one takes us seriously well
I say it's enough we've dealt with
enough abuse and bashing by the media
saying that gaming is a mental disorder
I think not
join me fellow gamers and together we
will rise let's review some other gamers
to perhaps inspire you that's right
everybody it doesn't matter where you're
from as long as you eat sleep for
tonight repeat you're in huh don't piss
me off I'm close to leveling up and you
look like just enough experience he's
gonna thrash you have you ever seen
anyone wearing these shirts I wanted to
buy one so badly I don't understand why
I'm not gonna spend money on something
ironic to wear that system we must
protect veronica from chad but society
is holding us back
damn you society the thing about gamers
is that we're not just good with our
thumbs we're also good with our minds
there is people in the world it really
makes you think truly makes you think
it's almost like we live in a society
don't f with the Skyrim player we will
suck your dick okay this is chad is the
main character or fortnight Season 5
stupid attractive big volge alpha male
WTF epic gamers this is not epic at all
this is a blatant insult to us gamers we
are the biggest supporters of fortnight
not Chad and we were myself that's right
fried months is over boo-hoo-hoo it's
time for game
my mind live a like on this video if
you're an epic gamer right now just like
me and Sonic of course LGBTQ eg epic
gamer why don't we get recognized like
we deserve F gamers what did you say an
F gaming I said fu gamer big mistake new
wait no please don't put you eat that's
right everybody sometimes we go savage
mode and we pone repression then and
oppression now this is an ocean this
isn't no gamers though you are not
allowed to play games in this library
[Music]
wait Logan Paul is a gamer Logan Paul
gets starring law-and-order
SUV in 2015 as an angry gamer who starts
a campaign on harassment against a
female of game developer Logan Logan
together we will rise I didn't know I
didn't know I swear I didn't know I
didn't know gamer headset it's on
knuckles yeah they're cracked feeding up
oh yeah ace epic gamer time good evening
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
I'm but more importantly Veronica you
still have yet to call me back I'm just
gonna you have 24 hours to make that
call and I will unleash the full might
of a gamer army upon you gamer
fear not Veronica I'll save you I'm so
happy I get to see my chat again we live
in a society we're living our society
guys the meme is back apparently it's
not a meme it's actually the fact we are
living in a society and don't take it
just from me take it from woke number
5000 epic gamer
Kanye West we live in a society he just
knows guys I'm not a player I'm a gamer
because players gets chicks what I get
is arrested for possession of child okay
this is not epic who changed this gamers
rice me me a gamer society this meme was
made by Baynes one Chad society Veronica
why does Chad get Veronica this Veronica
no my Katie is way higher just Veronica
not know that any time a girl boys
enters in the videogame I always say wow
a girl in a video game you know I want
you to know that I'm actually exclusive
with another girl named Veronica so
don't expect me to do anything special
for you like I would do for my gf
Veronica like giving our health potions
like taking tank damage for her okay
that is just for Veronica random girl
online I don't care about you all right
I have a lot of line lists of girls that
I could go with all right but my heart
belongs to Veronica all right just want
to make that clear one time that was in
a video game and a girl joined and my
teammate said Wow are you playing in the
kitchen and I say do bread that is not a
baby girls are gamers too
else are gamers to stay with me girls
are gamers too gross are gamers to
gamers will rise up together
[Laughter]
epic gamer epic gamer number one I hate
you don't care you're stupid
whatever you're ugly say what you're
ugly
well we saw are you gaming is [ __ ]
now you take that back the only way to
make me study even then as an epic gamer
I would still be able to play on I don't
care my passion for gaming are gross any
pain any suffering gaming for life
gaming forever gaming for the universe
gamers are not really impressed says
society what did you say
snack this is going in my crunch
compilation and I don't even care what
you have to say about it
do you still underestimate the power of
a gamer you can call me a loser in real
life any day but in this society you're
the loser but in my epic gaming world
I'm slaying dwarven mages I'm slaying
dwarma gnomes left and right do you know
how many girlfriends I have online they
killed Jesus because he was a gamer but
that's why he rose up and we must follow
him a gamer feminism Marxism
not being are they making fun of
veterans gets PTSD but us gamers we get
wsd a you think you had it tough and
numb try go to molten core with only
four healers okay grandpa I don't care
about your Vietnam stories have you ever
tried going to molten core with only
four healers
I don't care you may think I'm a loser
in real life but in the gaming world
you're the loser
together us gamers are strong for too
long we have been oppressed by all these
groups everyone is against us but we are
the toughest most hard-working most
vigilant most powerful group on the
Internet if we all together will rise up
we can defeat anything we can take over
the world we can create the gaming
utopia that we all wanted to live with
cars are not cars their game ours houses
are not houses their gaming studios
roads are not roads their candy crush
displays imagine it just think about how
good things could really be think about
how bad we are now because we haven't
raisin up yet the more we wait the
harder it will get but now is the time
for gamers to rice together leave a like
to show that you support this cause yeah
tea and oh I have an epic kill stream
where do you work out a game stuff
Emma Watson it's sad that we live in a
society Emma Watson epic gamer comes
firm
[Music]
you